Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Dawn in the city by the river. As the streets come to life, you haul yourself up from the gutter. Your name is Basim ibn Ishaq, and once, when your father was working on the great mosque of Samarra, you might have been somebody. But he was cast into exile and died a poor man. And you have grown up here in the streets of the old capital, a beggar, a nobody, a thief in the shadows of the ninth century. Already the streets around you are bustling with people,
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。河畔之城的黎明。当街道开始苏醒，你从阴沟里爬起来。你的名字叫巴辛·伊本·伊沙克（Basim ibn Ishaq），曾经，当你父亲在萨马拉大清真寺工作时，你或许也算个人物。但他被流放，最终贫困潦倒而死。而你在这座古都的街头长大，是个乞丐，是个无名小卒，是九世纪阴影中的一个小偷。你周围的街道已经熙熙攘攘，
the uncounted souls who live here in the round city. Merchants and traders, hawkers and hustlers, slave girls and soldiers from every corner of the earth, from the shores of Africa, the deserts of Arabia, the frozen wastes of the north, the far steps of the east. This is the city founded by the Caliph Al-Mansur, home to a million people. This is the city of peace, the greatest, richest, most colourful, most popular city on earth. This is Baghdad.
住在这座圆城里数不清的灵魂。来自世界各个角落的商人和贸易商、小贩和骗子、奴隶女孩和士兵，从非洲海岸、阿拉伯沙漠、北方冰原，到东方遥远的草原。这就是哈里发曼苏尔（Al-Mansur）建立的城市，容纳了百万人。这就是和平之城，地球上最伟大、最富有、最绚丽、最受欢迎的城市。这就是巴格达。
So, Tom. Dun, dun, dun. So, this is the setting for the video game assassin's creed mirage which is out tom as you will know at the end of this week and we talked in our library of alexandria episode about this franchise they've sold more than 200 million copies and they have these very intricately designed historical settings but never i think more colourful or more exciting than this, 9th century Baghdad. It's interesting, isn't it? Because you alluded to the one in Alexandria. What have they had? They've had one set in-
那么，汤姆。当，当，当。这就是电子游戏《刺客信条：幻景》（Assassin's Creed Mirage）的背景，正如你所知，它将在本周末发布。我们在之前的“亚历山大图书馆”一集中谈到过这个系列，它们已经售出了超过 2 亿份，拥有设计极其精巧的历史背景，但我认为没有比这座 9 世纪的巴格达更绚丽、更令人兴奋的了。这很有趣，不是吗？因为你提到了亚历山大的那一部。他们还有过什么？他们还有一部背景设定在——
French Revolution. Revolutionary Paris. So cities that have a kind of popular global resonance. And Baghdad obviously does. It's the city of the Arabian Nights, of Harun al-Rashid, Ali Baba, all that kind of thing. Saddam Hussein. But also Saddam Hussein. And that's the issue, isn't it? That probably, if you say to most people now Baghdad, they would think of death squads and the Iraq war. Did you ever watch the Banana Splits, Dominic?
法国大革命。革命时期的巴黎。所以这些城市都具有某种全球性的流行共鸣。巴格达显然也是。它是《一千零一夜》的城市，是哈伦·拉希德（Harun al-Rashid）、阿里巴巴，诸如此类的城市。萨达姆·侯赛因。但也包括萨达姆·侯赛因。这就是问题所在，不是吗？如果现在对大多数人说“巴格达”，他们可能会想到行刑队和伊拉克战争。多米尼克，你看过《香蕉船》（Banana Splits）吗？
I did in the 70s. Yeah. Yeah. So the Banana Splits were what? They were kind of lovable cartoon characters going around in cars, running into each other. And they had some cartoons and one of them was called the Arabian nights KN. And I remember there was one of them who, who had the ability to transform himself and he would say size of a hunting bird or something. And he would become a hunting bird. So for me as a child, Baghdad was absolutely this romantic place of Arabian night style glamour. And it is one of the great poetic cities, a city of myth. And we will go on to look at that. So we'll look at the Arabian nights and the degree to which they actually did originate in Baghdad. But I think the other point to make about Baghdad is that it is a massively globally significant city for
我在 70 年代看过。是的。那么《香蕉船》是什么？它们是一些可爱的卡通人物，开着车到处跑，互相碰撞。他们还有一些动画片，其中一部叫《阿拉伯之夜》。我记得里面有一个角色，他有变身的能力，他会说“狩猎鸟的大小”之类的。然后他就会变成一只狩猎鸟。所以对我这个孩子来说，巴格达绝对是一个充满《阿拉伯之夜》风格魅力的浪漫之地。它是伟大的诗意城市之一，是一座神话之城。我们将继续探讨这一点。我们会看看《阿拉伯之夜》，以及它们在多大程度上确实起源于巴格达。但我认为关于巴格达的另一点是，它是一座在全球历史上具有巨大意义的城市，
the vast sweep of history, because the story of how it comes to be founded and then to flourish is essentially the story of how Islam itself evolves to become the civilization that we would recognize today. So I would say we're going to do four episodes on Baghdad, the story of how it comes to be founded, its golden age, the legends that surround it. I would say that these episodes are as influential on global history as any episodes we've done. Right, because this is a huge sort of transition moment in world history. The development of a, I mean, we're looking back a little bit, so it's the development of an Islamic empire, isn't it? But it's also the development of Islam's sense of itself.
因为它的建立及其随后的繁荣，本质上就是伊斯兰教如何演变成我们今天所认知的文明的故事。所以我想我们会做四期关于巴格达的节目，讲述它如何建立、它的黄金时代以及围绕它的传说。我认为这些节目对全球历史的影响力不亚于我们做过的任何节目。没错，因为这是世界历史上一个巨大的转型时刻。伊斯兰帝国的形成，我的意思是，我们是在回顾过去，所以这是伊斯兰帝国的形成，不是吗？但这也是伊斯兰教自我意识的形成。
Yeah. It's also the way in which the center of gravity of the Islamic world moves, isn't it? Because the Arabs have come out of the desert, they take the Eastern Roman Empire, and then they move back towards what used to be the old Persian heartland. It's basically how Islam becomes that little bit more Persian. We've done two episodes on early Islamic history, so we did one on Muhammad himself and we did one on the evolution of the Kaaba. In both of those, we were exploring the way in which the legends that are told about Muhammad, the origins of Islam, the emergence of the Islamic empire, how hard it can be to distinguish from the actual history. But I think the key argument that we were making in those episodes was that Islam does not emerge
是的。这也是伊斯兰世界重心转移的方式，不是吗？因为阿拉伯人从沙漠中走出来，占领了东罗马帝国，然后他们又回到了曾经的波斯腹地。这基本上就是伊斯兰教如何变得更加波斯化。我们已经做了两期关于早期伊斯兰历史的节目，一期是关于穆罕默德本人，另一期是关于克尔白（Kaaba）的演变。在那两期节目中，我们都在探索关于穆罕默德的传说、伊斯兰教的起源、伊斯兰帝国的崛起，以及将这些传说与真实历史区分开来有多么困难。但我认为我们在那些节目中提出的关键论点是，伊斯兰教并不是
fully formed, like kind of Athena emerging from the brow of Zeus, that it takes time to evolve. And the first great imperial dynasty of Islam, the Umayyads, are toppled and they're replaced by a new dynasty, the Abbasids, and it's the sword, the founding of Baghdad is seen as a kind of punctuation point where that transitional process, the process by which Islam emerges from antiquity, from the Roman and the Persian worlds, it's a really, really significant break. So I know that we've begun by saying we're going to do four episodes on Baghdad. Actually, in this episode, I just want to set the scene and Baghdad will still not be founded by the end of the episode. Craigie, that's a terrible spoiler, Tom. But the portrait we give of the late Umayyad world,
完全成型地出现，就像雅典娜从宙斯的额头中诞生那样，它需要时间来演变。伊斯兰教的第一个伟大帝国王朝——倭马亚王朝（Umayyads）被推翻，取而代之的是一个新的王朝——阿拔斯王朝（Abbasids）。巴格达的建立被视为一个标点符号，标志着那个转型过程的终结。伊斯兰教从古代、从罗马和波斯世界中脱颖而出的过程，是一个非常、非常重大的转折。我知道我们开头说要拍四期关于巴格达的节目。实际上，在这一集中，我只想设定背景，到本集结束时，巴格达甚至还没有建立。克雷吉，那是个糟糕的剧透，汤姆。但我们所描绘的倭马亚王朝末期的世界，
it's a portrait of the circumstances from which this extraordinary revolution that brings the Abbasids to power and culminates in the founding of Baghdad. So I hope that people will listen to it and not feel that it's completely irrelevant to the story we want to tell. No, no. It's a great moment, isn't it? It's a great watershed in the transition from late antiquity to the medieval world. A kind of classical Islamic empire.
描绘了那场将阿拔斯王朝推上权力巅峰并最终导致巴格达建立的非凡革命的背景。所以我希望人们听了之后不会觉得它与我们要讲的故事完全无关。不，不。这是一个伟大的时刻，不是吗？这是从古典时代晚期到中世纪世界的一个伟大分水岭。一个古典的伊斯兰帝国。
So let's start by, in the broadest brush, painting the scene, Tom. So the beginning of what, the seventh century, the Arab armies have carried the messenger Muhammad out of the deserts. They have absolutely wiped the floor with the Eastern Roman Empire, with the Persians. And they've created an empire that actually, when we talk about empires, we always think of colonial empires or we think of the Romans, but this is one of the greatest empires in human history isn't it the arab empire and it's staggering how quickly they put it together yeah so it's it's much larger than the roman empire it's probably um by the early 8th century so a century or so after the death of Muhammad, it's about 5 million square miles.
那么让我们从最宏观的角度开始，描绘一下当时的场景，汤姆。七世纪初，阿拉伯军队将先知穆罕默德的教义带出了沙漠。他们彻底击败了东罗马帝国和波斯人。他们建立了一个帝国，实际上，当我们谈论帝国时，我们总是想到殖民帝国或罗马帝国，但这难道不是人类历史上最伟大的帝国之一吗？阿拉伯帝国，他们建立它的速度之快令人震惊。是的，它比罗马帝国大得多，可能在 8 世纪初，也就是穆罕默德去世一个世纪左右，它大约有 500 万平方英里。
It extends from the Atlantic right the way up to the walls of China. The process of conquest has revolved around the dismembering of the Roman Empire. So the Arabs have conquered Syria, Palestine, Egypt. They've spread along the North African coast. They've invaded Spain. They've crossed the Pyrenees. They're kind of probing the defenses of the Frankish kingdom. Eastwards, they have swallowed the Persian empire entire. So the Persian empire ruled by a dynasty called the Sasanians. The Sasanians have a kind of sacred bloodline. It is believed by the Persians that this bloodline has been appointed by God. Most of the subjects of the Sasanians, the Persians, that this bloodline has been appointed by God. Most of the subjects of the Sasanians, the Persians, are Zoroastrian. They believe in a world that is divided into good and
它从大西洋一直延伸到中国的长城。征服的过程围绕着对罗马帝国的肢解。阿拉伯人征服了叙利亚、巴勒斯坦、埃及。他们沿着北非海岸扩张。他们入侵了西班牙。他们越过了比利牛斯山脉。他们正在试探法兰克王国的防御。向东，他们吞并了整个波斯帝国。波斯帝国由一个叫萨珊王朝（Sasanians）的王朝统治。萨珊人有一种神圣的血统。波斯人相信这种血统是上帝指定的。萨珊人的大多数臣民，即波斯人，都是琐罗亚斯德教徒（拜火教徒）。他们相信一个分为善与
evil. It's believed that a kind of apocalyptic reckoning will come. But all of these Sasanian possessions have been swallowed up. And the last Sasanian king has kind of fled eastwards trying to reach China and died in a region called Khorasan. So Khorasan, it's northeast in Iran now, it's Afghanistan, it's Central Asia, and it's dotted with oasis cities that still have a resonance to this day. So Samarkand, Herat, brilliantly named Merv. And that has been conquered by about 705, 706. And then there's the Oxus River, and that's been crossed. And they're coming up, they're approaching China. So they've gone further than Alexander. Absolutely. I would say that no dynasty in history has presided over a greater array of conquests than the Umayyads. And so therefore they have this enormous sweep of conquests.
恶的世界。人们相信一种末日审判将会到来。但所有这些萨珊人的领地都被吞并了。最后一位萨珊国王逃往东方，试图到达中国，并死在一个叫呼罗珊（Khorasan）的地区。所以呼罗珊，现在是伊朗东北部，是阿富汗，是中亚，那里点缀着至今仍有回响的绿洲城市。比如撒马尔罕、赫拉特，还有名字很棒的梅尔夫。到 705 年、706 年左右，这些地方已经被征服了。然后是阿姆河（Oxus River），也被跨越了。他们正在逼近中国。所以他们走得比亚历山大还远。绝对是。我认为历史上没有任何王朝比倭马亚王朝主持过更宏大的征服。因此，他们拥有如此巨大的征服版图。
And this is an age when it is taken for granted that things do not happen in the world without the say-so of God. So the Umayyads can point to the vastness of the sweep of their conquests and say, this proves that we are indeed what we say we are, the deputies of God, the caliphs. So Tom, just on the Umayyads, so they're not the original people who had taken Islam out of the desert, are they? They're a successor dynasty. Well, again, it's very confusing because there's a lot of kind of propaganda, Umayyad propaganda and anti-Umayyad propaganda surrounding this. According to Muslim historians, they come from Mecca, but there is also a very strong tradition that they had made their fortune trading with the Romans, which implies that they probably came from the borders of Palestine or Syria, actually, because they built the Dome of the Rock in Jerusalem. Jerusalem is very important to them. And they make their capital in Damascus, the capital of Syria. So that seems to be their native land. They're essentially a Syrian dynasty. And they come to power after four commanders of the faithful, four caliphs who will be commemorated by Islamic tradition as the Rashidun, the righteously guided.
这是一个理所当然的时代，即没有上帝的旨意，世界上就不会发生任何事情。所以倭马亚人可以指出他们征服版图的广阔，并说，这证明了我们确实是我们所说的那样，是上帝的代理人，是哈里发。那么汤姆，关于倭马亚人，他们不是最初将伊斯兰教带出沙漠的人，对吧？他们是一个继任王朝。嗯，这又很令人困惑，因为周围有很多宣传，倭马亚的宣传和反倭马亚的宣传。根据穆斯林历史学家的说法，他们来自麦加，但也有一个非常强烈的传统，认为他们是通过与罗马人贸易发家的，这意味着他们可能实际上来自巴勒斯坦或叙利亚的边境，因为他们在耶路撒冷建造了圆顶清真寺。耶路撒冷对他们非常重要。他们将首都定在叙利亚的首府大马士革。所以那似乎是他们的故土。他们本质上是一个叙利亚王朝。他们是在四位正统哈里发之后掌权的，这四位哈里发被伊斯兰传统纪念为“拉希顿”（Rashidun），即受引导的正统哈里发。
So that's Abu Bakr, Umar, Uthman, and Ali. And Ali is a key figure in this story because he is both the cousin and the son-in-law of Muhammad. He rules as a caliph, but he ends up assassinated and he leaves behind children. And the question of what the role of his bloodline should be is going to be a kind of key part of this story. But before we come to all that, by the 740s, although the Umayyads are the masters of this vast empire, there is a kind of growing mood of crisis because for the first time they're starting to experience military reverses. So in 732, a raiding party going northwards into the land of the Franks up to the great shrine of St. Martin in Tours is defeated. At the opposite end of the Islamic world, in Trans-Oxania, so approaching China, the armies of Islam had defeated a battle
也就是阿布·伯克尔、欧麦尔、奥斯曼和阿里。阿里是这个故事中的关键人物，因为他既是穆罕默德的堂弟，也是他的女婿。他作为哈里发统治，但最终被暗杀，留下了子女。他的血统应该扮演什么角色，将成为这个故事的关键部分。但在我们谈到这一切之前，到 740 年代，尽管倭马亚人是这个庞大帝国的主人，但一种危机感正在增长，因为他们第一次开始经历军事挫折。所以在 732 年，一支向北进入法兰克人领地、到达图尔圣马丁大教堂的突袭部队被击败了。在伊斯兰世界的另一端，在河中地区（Trans-Oxania），即接近中国的地方，伊斯兰军队在 717 年的一场战役中被击败，
called Aksu in 717. And that basically means that they lose northern Trans-Oxania. The armies of Islam had defeated a battle called Aksu in 717, and that basically means that they lose northern Transoxania. The greatest enemy, of course, faced by the caliphate is the surviving rump of the Roman Empire with its capital in Constantinople, and the Umayyads have twice tried to capture it. So in 674, and then again in 716 to 717, vast amphibious invasions of the great city of the Caesars, but it holds out. And so in the decades that follow, you start to get sayings that are attributed to the prophet saying that Byzantium will never fall, that the people of Rum are like rock and water. They will be with you till the end of time. And this is bad for the Umayyad reputation because their legitimacy to a degree has been founded on a sense of their invincibility.
那场战役叫阿克苏（Aksu）。这基本上意味着他们失去了河中地区的北部。伊斯兰军队在 717 年的一场战役中被击败，那场战役叫阿克苏，这基本上意味着他们失去了河中地区的北部。当然，哈里发国面临的最大敌人是罗马帝国的残余，其首都在君士坦丁堡，倭马亚人曾两次试图占领它。所以在 674 年，以及 716 年到 717 年，对这座凯撒之城进行了大规模的两栖入侵，但它坚持住了。因此，在随后的几十年里，开始出现归因于先知的言论，说拜占庭永远不会陷落，说罗马人就像岩石和水。他们将与你同在，直到时间的尽头。这对倭马亚人的声誉很不利，因为他们的合法性在一定程度上建立在他们不可战胜的感觉之上。
So up to that point, Tom, had they envisaged themselves as living in a sort of a unipolar world where they would be the only super bearer and now they have to accept that every empire has its limits and they have theirs and they have to accept
所以在那之前，汤姆，他们是否设想自己生活在一个单极世界中，他们是唯一的超级大国，而现在他们必须接受每个帝国都有其局限性，他们也有自己的局限性，他们必须接受
that there are going to be other geopolitical powers, you know, the Romans or whoever, and they have to live within those boundaries. I think they continue to hope that they will conquer Byzantium and that the conquest will continue. But there is definitely a sense that perhaps the conquest of the world isn't going to be quite as easy as they had assumed in the kind of heady days when it seemed that God was giving them victories wherever they went. So there's trouble on the frontiers. At the same time, there are all kinds of sectarian conflicts going on within Islam itself. And these date back to the reign of Ali, which we talked about. So that's back in the 7th century. So the guy who was assassinated.
会有其他的地缘政治力量，你知道，罗马人或其他什么人，他们必须在这些边界内生活。我认为他们继续希望他们能征服拜占庭，征服会继续下去。但肯定有一种感觉，也许征服世界并不像他们在那些头脑发热的日子里所假设的那样容易，当时似乎上帝在他们所到之处都赐予他们胜利。所以边境上有麻烦。与此同时，伊斯兰教内部也发生了各种宗派冲突。这些冲突可以追溯到阿里的统治时期，我们谈到过。也就是 7 世纪的那个人。那个被暗杀的人。
The guy who was assassinated, the cousin and the son-in-law of the prophet. So the people who are responsible for Ali's assassination, this is a group of people called the Karajites, which literally mean those who go out. And these are people who, they're in Ali's army. They feel that Ali is basically a heretic, that he is not measuring up to the high standards that they would expect from a Muslim, let alone a blood relative and marriage relative of the Prophet. Why? What's he doing? Because the Karajites are reading the Quran, which preaches a very radical kind of egalitarianism. Justice and equality are very, very fundamental to the moral teachings of the Quran. And they argue that actually, you know, the true aristocracy in Islam
那个被暗杀的人，先知的堂弟和女婿。所以那些对阿里被暗杀负责的人，这是一群被称为“哈瓦利吉派”（Karajites）的人，字面意思是“走出去的人”。这些人，他们在阿里的军队里。他们觉得阿里基本上是个异端，他没有达到他们对穆斯林所期望的高标准，更不用说先知的血亲和姻亲了。为什么？他在做什么？因为哈瓦利吉派在阅读《古兰经》，它宣扬一种非常激进的平等主义。正义和平等是《古兰经》道德教义中非常、非常基础的部分。他们认为，实际上，你知道，伊斯兰教中真正的贵族
should be one of piety, not of blood. And therefore, if a slave is more devoted to God than, say, the cousin of Muhammad, then he is more righteous. And this is a notion that Ali is not prepared to tolerate. And so he kind of expels them from his army. And the Karajites are, I mean, to the degree that you can find forebears of the Islamic state in the 7th century or the 8th century, I mean, it's kind of very anachronistic to say so. But the Karajites would be the parallel. They are very, very brutal. There are all kinds of stories of them slicing open the bellies
应该是虔诚的贵族，而不是血统的贵族。因此，如果一个奴隶比穆罕默德的堂弟更虔诚，那么他就更正义。这是一个阿里不准备容忍的观念。所以他把他们从军队中驱逐了出去。哈瓦利吉派是，我的意思是，在某种程度上，你可以在 7 世纪或 8 世纪找到伊斯兰国的先驱，我的意思是，说他们是先驱有点时代错误。但哈瓦利吉派会是那个对应物。他们非常、非常残忍。有各种各样的故事说他们剖开
of those whom they condemn as infidels. They go into marketplaces cloaked with swords hidden underneath their cloaks. They'll draw the swords out and just kind of turn and turn like whirling dervishes, killing as many people as they can until they're killed. So very, very kind of intimidating, frightening figures, a kind of murderous piety. And Ali sees them as the dangerous opponents to sane rule that they are. And he militarily crushes them in 658. But then three years later, one of them succeeds in murdering him while he's at prayers in the great city of Kufa, which is a kind of
那些被他们谴责为异教徒的人的肚子。他们披着斗篷走进市场，斗篷下藏着剑。他们会拔出剑，像旋转的苦行僧一样转来转去，尽可能多地杀人，直到他们自己被杀。所以是非常、非常令人生畏、可怕的人物，一种杀戮的虔诚。阿里认为他们是 sane 统治的危险对手，事实也确实如此。他在 658 年在军事上粉碎了他们。但三年后，其中一人成功地在他于伟大的库法城（Kufa）祈祷时谋杀了他，库法城是一种
equivalent of a Roman legionary base. It's a great military base for the Arabs built on the borders of Mesopotamia, so what's now Iraq. That's quite close to where, not that a million miles away from where they will end up founding Baghdad, right? It's absolutely that corner, yes. And Kufa will play a very important part because there That's quite close to where, not that a million miles away from where they will end up founding Baghdad, right? period right the way into the 8th century. And the most significant of these are kind of the opposites of the Karajites. The Karajites reject Ali's claim to be the legitimate heir of Muhammad because they say he's not pious enough. But there are those who say that Islam can only be ruled by the heirs of Ali. And these people become known as the Shia Ali, the Shia Ali. So these are the Shia, Shia Muslims. They're still with us to this day. And these are people in the seventh century who believe
相当于罗马军团基地的城市。它是阿拉伯人在美索不达米亚（即现在的伊拉克）边境建立的一个伟大的军事基地。那离他们最终建立巴格达的地方很近，对吧？绝对是那个角落，是的。库法将发挥非常重要的作用，因为那里……那离他们最终建立巴格达的地方很近，对吧？一直持续到 8 世纪。其中最重要的一派是哈瓦利吉派的对立面。哈瓦利吉派拒绝阿里作为穆罕默德合法继承人的主张，因为他们说他不够虔诚。但也有人说，伊斯兰教只能由阿里的继承人统治。这些人被称为“阿里党”（Shia Ali）。所以这就是什叶派，什叶派穆斯林。他们至今仍与我们同在。这些人是 7 世纪相信
that Ali's sons, who are obviously also the grandsons of the prophet, should rule. These grandsons are denied the rule of the caliphate by the Umayyads. One of them is killed at Karbala. Again, still a great place of pilgrimage outside what is now Baghdad for the Shia. And the Umayy what is now Baghdad for the Shia. And the Umayyads have every stake in crushing the Shia as they do the Karajites. But the Shia remain, and they kind of basically take a leaf out of the Sasanian book. So you remember I said that the conviction of Zoroastrians in the Sasanian Empire is that the Sasanian royal dynasty are essentially divinely appointed, that this is a divinely sanctioned bloodline. So this is Persia, right?
阿里的儿子们（显然也是先知的孙子们）应该统治的人。这些孙子被倭马亚人剥夺了哈里发的统治权。其中一人在卡尔巴拉（Karbala）被杀。同样，这仍然是什叶派在现在巴格达郊外的一个伟大的朝圣地。倭马亚人像对待哈瓦利吉派一样，不惜一切代价粉碎什叶派。但什叶派依然存在，他们基本上从萨珊人的书中借鉴了一点。所以你还记得我说过，萨珊帝国中琐罗亚斯德教徒的信念是，萨珊皇室本质上是神圣任命的，这是一种神圣认可的血统。所以这是波斯，对吧？
Yes. That conviction essentially migrates to the descendants of Ali. So Tom, is that why to this day, Persia, aka Iran, is a hotbed of Shia or Shiites, as people might call them? No, it becomes Shiite much later, I think in the 16th century. Okay. But you could, I mean, it has been argued that there is a kind of implicit buried Zoroastrianism that fuses with Shiism that does perhaps explain it. It's a very complicated territory. I think the key thing is that at this point, these various factions, these various
是的。这种信念本质上迁移到了阿里的后裔身上。所以汤姆，这就是为什么直到今天，波斯（即伊朗）是什叶派的温床吗？不，我认为它在 16 世纪才变得什叶派化。好吧。但你可以，我的意思是，有人认为有一种隐含的、被掩埋的琐罗亚斯德教与什叶派融合，这也许能解释它。这是一个非常复杂的领域。我认为关键在于，在这一点上，这些不同的派系，这些不同的
sectarian divisions are still very much alive. They're kind of fusing. So again, under the Umayyads, there's a kind of brilliant figure who gets thrown up. This is the process of civil wars that sees Abdul Malik, the great Umayyad caliph, who ends up building the Dome of the Rock. While he is busy establishing his rule in Syria, this figure appears in Iraq, who is commemorated as Muqtada the deceiver, who seizes the treasury in Kufa, gives it all away to the poor. So again, you see this kind of sense of radical egalitarianism, the sense that the poor can claim justice from the rich, urging a revolution, saying that all men should be equal, claiming to
宗派分裂仍然非常活跃。它们正在融合。所以，在倭马亚王朝下，出现了一个天才人物。这就是内战的过程，见证了阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik），那位最终建造了圆顶清真寺的伟大倭马亚哈里发。当他忙于在叙利亚建立统治时，这个人物出现在伊拉克，他被纪念为“骗子穆赫塔尔”（Muqtada the deceiver），他夺取了库法的国库，把钱全部分给了穷人。所以，你再次看到了这种激进的平等主义感，穷人可以向富人要求正义的感觉，煽动革命，说所有人应该平等，声称
be a prophet, and huge excitement because he has, Dominic, a magic chair. Oh, crikey. Which he parades around. I love a magic chair, like the wishing chair in Enid Blyton, Tom. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So he's a kind of tremendous figure.
自己是先知，并引起了巨大的轰动，因为他，多米尼克，有一把魔椅。哦，天哪。他带着它到处游行。我喜欢魔椅，就像伊妮德·布莱顿（Enid Blyton）书里的许愿椅一样，汤姆。是的，完全正确。完全正确。所以他是一个了不起的人物。
And it's said by his supporters that he's accompanied by angels on horses of fire. Actually, his followers are kind of terrifying cudgel bearers, they're called. And they end up kind of beating everyone up. And so this sense that militant piety can shade into extreme violence is a continuing theme throughout this period. And it explains actually why Amayadrul comes to be welcomed. So Mukhtar the deceiver ends up killed. His severed hand is nailed to the mosqueiver ends up killed. His severed hand is nailed to the mosque in Kufa. His chair is burned, but he comes to be revered by the Shia
他的支持者说，他有骑着火马的天使陪伴。实际上，他的追随者是一群可怕的棍棒手，他们被称为“棍棒手”。他们最终把每个人都打了一顿。所以这种激进的虔诚可以演变成极端暴力的感觉，是这一时期持续存在的主题。这实际上解释了为什么倭马亚的统治会受到欢迎。所以骗子穆赫塔尔最终被杀。他被砍下的手被钉在库法的清真寺上。他的椅子被烧毁了，但他被什叶派尊为
as a supporter of Ali. And in the 740s, you have a whole kind of renewal of Karajite uprisings, of Shia uprisings, because these are people who are looking at the military defeats on the frontiers, looking at the wealth and the splendor of the Umayyad caliphs and saying, these are un-Islamic figures. God does not favor them. He wants a new dispensation. And in 745, the Karajites actually proclaimed their own caliph and managed to secure a big kind of chunk of Iraq. So none of this is good for the Umayyads, but I think it would have been manageable for them if it wasn't for the fact that something else is also happening, which will in the long run be terminal for the Umayyads themselves, but even more seismically,
阿里的支持者。在 740 年代，你看到哈瓦利吉派起义、什叶派起义的全面复兴，因为这些人看着边境上的军事失败，看着倭马亚哈里发的财富和辉煌，说，这些人是非伊斯兰的人物。上帝不偏爱他们。他想要一个新的秩序。在 745 年，哈瓦利吉派实际上宣布了他们自己的哈里发，并设法控制了伊拉克的一大片地区。所以这一切对倭马亚人来说都不是好事，但我认为如果不是因为发生了另一件事，这对他们来说本来是可以控制的，这件事从长远来看对倭马亚人本身是致命的，但更具地震性的是，
be hugely influential on the growth and development of Islam. And essentially, it's a process that will culminate in the development of the kind of Islam that is by far the largest form, what we call Sunni Islam. And I think we should maybe take a break now. And when we come back, we can look at exactly what Sunni Islam is, how it develops, and exactly why it's so menacing for the Umayyads and the role that it will come to play in the revolution that overthrows the Umayyads and brings the Abbasids to power. We'll find out more after your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute, what kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order?
它将对伊斯兰教的成长和发展产生巨大的影响。本质上，这是一个最终导致伊斯兰教最大分支——我们所说的逊尼派伊斯兰教——发展的过程。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们可以看看逊尼派伊斯兰教到底是什么，它是如何发展的，以及为什么它对倭马亚人如此具有威胁性，以及它将在推翻倭马亚王朝并使阿拔斯王朝掌权的革命中发挥什么作用。在你的咖啡馆名字“朱莉娅”之后，我们会了解更多。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等，朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？
But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this, because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自己做。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to TheRestIsEntertainment.com. That's TheRestIs the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history so we have been in what is now iraq we're eventually going to get to the founding of the great city of baghdad but we're setting very carefully setting out the context for it so tom we've been talking about the Umayyad dynasty. They're based in Damascus in Syria. They're presiding over this empire that is very fractious. They've suffered a series of defeats. There are all kinds of sectarian, millenarian movements that are
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。那是 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们一直在现在的伊拉克，我们最终会到达伟大的巴格达城的建立，但我们正在非常仔细地为它设定背景。所以汤姆，我们一直在谈论倭马亚王朝。他们以叙利亚的大马士革为基地。他们统治着这个非常分裂的帝国。他们遭受了一系列失败。有各种各样的宗派、千禧年运动在
challenging their authority. But you said before the break that this might have been manageable were it not for this development a long way away. So we're going to get to that, aren't we? But do you want to talk a bit about the kind of people that the Umayyads are ruling, the population whose support they need? Right. So I think there's always a temptation when you think of the coming of Islam. You think there's the Romans and the Persians and then the Arabs conquer it. And basically everyone in the
挑战他们的权威。但你在休息前说，如果不是因为这个发生在很远地方的发展，这本来是可以控制的。所以我们要讲到那个了，不是吗？但你想谈谈倭马亚人统治的那种人，他们需要支持的人口吗？好的。所以我认为当你想到伊斯兰教的到来时，总会有一种诱惑。你认为有罗马人和波斯人，然后阿拉伯人征服了它。基本上中东的每个人
Middle East becomes Muslim. This is absolutely not the case. The Arabs are a very tiny minority, ruling lands that are absolutely teeming with different peoples, with different traditions, and perhaps most importantly, with different understandings of the divine. So if you look at the heartlands of the caliphate, so Syria, Palestine, Egypt, the lands that had been ruled by the Romans and Iraq and Iran, the lands that had been ruled by the Persians, by the Sasanians, the largest number of people there are Christians. This is a very, very Christian world in the seventh and eighth centuries. They're world um in the 7th and 8th centuries they're obviously dominant in the the former Roman provinces but there are also an awful lot of them in the former Sasanian empire um so there are a lot of Christians in Mesopotamia you also of course have the
都变成了穆斯林。这绝对不是事实。阿拉伯人是一个非常小的少数群体，统治着充满不同民族、不同传统，也许最重要的是，对神有不同理解的土地。所以如果你看看哈里发国的腹地，即叙利亚、巴勒斯坦、埃及，那些曾经由罗马人统治的土地，以及伊拉克和伊朗，那些曾经由波斯人、萨珊人统治的土地，那里最大的人群是基督徒。在 7 世纪和 8 世纪，这是一个非常、非常基督教的世界。他们显然在以前的罗马省份中占主导地位，但以前的萨珊帝国中也有很多基督徒，所以美索不达米亚有很多基督徒。当然，你还有
Zoroastrians who we mentioned in the first half for them the overthrow of the Sasanians is devastating because they had seen the Sasanian dynasty as a kind of a pledge that God was on their side. Dare I say the sacral quality of the Sasanian bloodline. But Tom, a quick question. Why is that more devastating for the people in the old Persian empire, the Zoroastrians, than the loss of their territory is for the Christians and the former Roman Empire? Is it because the Christians, they didn't need to be in an officially Christian state because they had a different conception of... Right. Because Christians have flourished in Mesopotamia, despite the fact that it's the Zoroastrian king ruling Iran and Iraq. They don't have to worry
我们在上半部分提到的琐罗亚斯德教徒，对他们来说，萨珊王朝的覆灭是毁灭性的，因为他们一直将萨珊王朝视为上帝站在他们一边的保证。敢说萨珊血统的神圣性。但汤姆，一个快速的问题。为什么这对旧波斯帝国的琐罗亚斯德教徒来说，比失去领土对基督徒和前罗马帝国的人来说更具毁灭性？是因为基督徒，他们不需要在一个官方的基督教国家，因为他们有不同的概念……对。因为基督徒在美索不达米亚繁荣发展，尽管萨珊国王统治着伊朗和伊拉克。他们不必担心
about it. And it doesn't, you know, Christianity flourished long before Constantine converted to Christianity and before the Roman emperors became Christian. So that's fine. There's a kind of, if you want to put it in anachronistic terms, there's a division between church and state for Christians, even in late antiquity. But there is no real division between church and state in the Persian world. And so therefore, the loss of the Sasanian dynasty is completely devastating. So we have a Zoroastrian priest in the wake of the Arab conquests mourning the faith is
它。而且，你知道，基督教在君士坦丁皈依基督教和罗马皇帝成为基督徒之前很久就已经繁荣了。所以这没问题。对于基督徒来说，即使在古代晚期，也存在一种——如果你想用时代错误的话来说——教会与国家的分离。但在波斯世界中，教会与国家之间没有真正的分离。因此，萨珊王朝的丧失是完全毁灭性的。所以我们在阿拉伯征服之后有一位琐罗亚斯德教祭司哀叹信仰是
ruined. The Shah and Shah, so the king of kings, he was slain like a dog. And the two are kind of, you know, he's equating the two. The loss of the Sasanian dynasty means that the faith is ruined. And there's a further tragedy for the Zoroastrians, which is that in the Quran, it's specified that those who follow the teachings of the prophet should allow the peoples of the book, as long as they acknowledge the supremacy of Islam, as long as they pay a tax called the jizya, they should be allowed the freedom to worship as they please.
毁灭的。万王之王（Shah and Shah）像狗一样被杀。两者是，你知道，他把两者等同起来。萨珊王朝的丧失意味着信仰的毁灭。对于琐罗亚斯德教徒来说，还有一个进一步的悲剧，那就是在《古兰经》中规定，那些遵循先知教义的人应该允许“有经人”（peoples of the book），只要他们承认伊斯兰教的至高无上，只要他们缴纳一种叫“吉兹亚”（jizya）的税，他们就应该被允许自由地以他们喜欢的方式崇拜。
And those are what, Jews and Christians? Jews and Christians and a mysterious people called the Sabaeans, who may be popping up later in this podcast. Nobody's entirely sure who the Sabaeans are, but the Jews and the Christians, absolutely. So Jews and Christians, it's fine. The Arabs do not go around kind of destroying synagogues or churches. They respect them.
那些是什么，犹太人和基督徒？犹太人和基督徒，以及一种叫“萨比人”（Sabaeans）的神秘民族，他们可能会在这个播客的后面出现。没人完全确定萨比人是谁，但犹太人和基督徒，绝对是。所以犹太人和基督徒，没问题。阿拉伯人不会到处破坏犹太教堂或教堂。他们尊重它们。
But the fire temples of the Zoroastrians, fire is sacred to Zoroaster. And across Iraq, across the Western fringes of Iran, these start to be destroyed. And it's actually only in the very remote regions of Khorasan, so Northeastern Iran, that the fire temples survive. And it's possible for the Zoroastrian priesthood and Zoroastrian worshipers to continue their faith as they had done back in their heyday under the Sasanian rulers. So you've got Christians, you've got Zoroastrians who are very, very unhappy. And then you have Jews and Jews like the Christians are much happier. And this is a golden age of Jewish scholarship. So you have Jews in Palestine who
但琐罗亚斯德教徒的火庙，火对琐罗亚斯德教来说是神圣的。在伊拉克各地，在伊朗的西部边缘，这些开始被摧毁。实际上，只有在呼罗珊的偏远地区，即伊朗东北部，火庙才得以幸存。琐罗亚斯德教祭司和崇拜者才有可能像他们在萨珊统治下的鼎盛时期那样继续他们的信仰。所以你有基督徒，你有非常、非常不高兴的琐罗亚斯德教徒。然后你有犹太人，犹太人像基督徒一样要快乐得多。这是犹太学术的黄金时代。所以你在巴勒斯坦有犹太人，他们
are great scholars, but the greatest centers of Jewish scholarship, towns called Surah and Pompidita in Mesopotamia. These are where the rabbis are developing the Talmud. And the Talmud is a vast kind of sprawling edifice of legal commentary. And then it's legal commentary on legal commentary on legal commentary, textual analysis, commentary on Torah. In these great Jewish centers of scholarship, you have the idea of teachings from God that are preserved in Torah that have literally come from God, that have been written by God on the tablets of stone brought down from Sinai by Moses. But you also have this other idea that there is a kind of vast legal complex that can be analyzed by these rabbis
是伟大的学者，但犹太学术最伟大的中心是美索不达米亚的苏拉（Surah）和庞贝迪塔（Pompidita）等城镇。这些是拉比们发展《塔木德》（Talmud）的地方。而《塔木德》是一个庞大的法律评论大厦。然后是法律评论的评论，再评论，文本分析，对《托拉》（Torah）的评论。在这些伟大的犹太学术中心，你有来自上帝的教义被保存在《托拉》中的想法，这些教义确实来自上帝，是由上帝写在摩西从西奈山带下来的石板上的。但你也有另一个想法，即存在一个庞大的法律体系，可以被这些拉比分析，
that is also kind of interfused with an understanding of God's purpose and the laws that he wants to govern God's people. And that sense of a written law and a spoken law is the kind of the great cultural innovation that the rabbis over the course of late antiquity in Palestine, but above all in Mesopotamia, have been developing. And so all these traditions are now subject to the Arabs, who are starting to develop what will become Islam. Just before you move on, so in other words, if you're an ordinary Christian or a Jew, you're plodding along, you're a baker or whatever, the coming of Islam and the Arab empire-
它也与对上帝旨意和上帝希望统治他子民的法律的理解相融合。这种书面法和口头法的意识是拉比在古代晚期，特别是在美索不达米亚，一直在发展的伟大文化创新。所以所有这些传统现在都受制于阿拉伯人，他们开始发展将成为伊斯兰教的东西。在你继续之前，换句话说，如果你是一个普通的基督徒或犹太人，你按部就班地生活，你是一个面包师或什么的，伊斯兰教和阿拉伯帝国的到来——
Doesn't make any difference. Yeah, it's kind of fine, right? You pay pay a tax which is probably a bit annoying yeah but on the other hand there were all kinds of you know controversies and bust-ups and stuff in the in the late eastern roman empire so you're probably glad that a lot of that has gone away and you've got a bit of order and i think it's it's more disruptive for christians than it is for jews in the in the former roman provinces, because Christians were accustomed to being the bosses, and now they go to being equivalent to the Jews. So the Jews have been forced to pay taxes to the Romans for the right to practice their faith, and now Christians are having to do the same. So it's a bit humiliating for them. They're a bit resentful of it. But no real skin off their nose. They can carry on doing what they do. It's all fine. And as I say, Christians remain vastly in the majority. And this for the Arabs is a problem because the risk is that they will be kind of swallowed up by the vast mass of Christians. And so right from the beginning, it's been important to the Arabs that they distinguish
没有任何区别。是的，这很好，对吧？你缴纳一种税，这可能有点烦人，但另一方面，在东罗马帝国晚期有各种各样的争议和冲突，所以你可能很高兴其中很多已经消失了，你得到了一点秩序。我认为对于前罗马省份的基督徒来说，这比对犹太人更具破坏性，因为基督徒习惯于当老板，现在他们变得和犹太人一样了。所以犹太人一直被迫为他们实践信仰的权利向罗马人纳税，现在基督徒也必须这样做。所以这对他们来说有点羞辱。他们对此有点怨恨。但对他们没什么真正的伤害。他们可以继续做他们做的事。一切都很好。正如我所说，基督徒仍然占绝大多数。这对阿拉伯人来说是一个问题，因为风险在于他们会被庞大的基督徒群体所吞没。所以从一开始，阿拉伯人就必须区分
themselves from their subject peoples, which is why, for instance, they found Kufa, this great military base, not in the heartlands of Mesopotamia, but right on the desert borders, so that they can preserve their desert purity, if you like. Right. Yeah. That they can maintain their identity. And because in early Islam, there is a sense that the Arabs, like the Jews, are descended by blood from Abraham. So Abraham has two sons. He has Isaac, from whom
他们自己和他们的臣民，这就是为什么，例如，他们建立了库法，这个伟大的军事基地，不是在美索不达米亚的腹地，而是在沙漠边缘，这样他们就可以保持他们的沙漠纯洁性，如果你愿意的话。对。是的。他们可以保持他们的身份。而且因为在早期伊斯兰教中，有一种感觉，阿拉伯人像犹太人一样，在血缘上是亚伯拉罕的后裔。所以亚伯拉罕有两个儿子。他有以撒，犹太人声称是他的后裔，他有以实玛利，阿拉伯人声称是他的后裔。所以对许多阿拉伯人来说，伊斯兰教被视为只为阿拉伯人准备的。所以他们绝对不希望非信徒皈依伊斯兰教。他们想在肥沃新月地带的边缘保持他们的身份，并保持他们的伊斯兰身份作为对他们独特的东西。现在，显然如果你是穆斯林，你会得到各种财政特权。犹太人、基督徒和琐罗亚斯德教徒都必须缴纳人头税和税款，这将使他们能够继续实践他们的信仰。所以如果你成为穆斯林，你就免除了这些。但阿拉伯人意识到这是一个他们必须防范的骗局。
the Jews claim descent, and he has Ishmael, from whom the Arabs claim descent. So for many Arabs, Islam is seen as being only for the Arabs. So they absolutely don't want non-believers to convert to Islam. They want to preserve their identity on the margins of the Fertile Crescent and also keep their Islamic identity as something that is distinctive to them. Now, obviously you get all kinds of fiscal privileges if you're a Muslim. Jews and Christians and Zoroastrians are all having to pay poll taxes and taxes that will enable them to continue practicing their faiths. So if you become a Muslim, you get out of that. But the Arabs are aware that this is a scam that they have to guard against.
所以他们用各种侮辱来限制皈依。所以犹太人、琐罗亚斯德教徒或基督徒仅仅服从上帝是不够的。他还必须服从一位阿拉伯赞助人。这，你知道，如果你是一个高贵的基督徒或琐罗亚斯德教徒显贵，你知道，你不想有效地成为一个仆人，一个阿拉伯人的附庸。汤姆，我们在我们的公立学校节目播出后录制这个。你已经从级长变成了“fag”（低年级仆役），对吧？完全正确。所以这对那些相对富有的人来说是一种特别的侮辱。
And so they hedge conversion about with all kinds of indignities. So it's not enough for a Jew or a Zoroastrian or a Christian to submit to God. He also has to submit himself to an Arab patron. And this, you know, if you're a kind of a highborn Christian or Zoroastrian dignitary, you know, you don't want to be effectively a kind of a servant, a placeman to an Arab. Tom, we're recording this today after our public school episodes came out. You've gone from being a prefect to being a fag, right? Exactly. So that's particularly, you know, that's particular indignity for those who are relatively well
因此，他们用各种屈辱来限制皈依。所以，对于一个犹太人、琐罗亚斯德教徒或基督徒来说，仅仅顺从上帝是不够的。他还必须顺从一位阿拉伯赞助人。你知道，如果你是一位出身高贵的基督徒或琐罗亚斯德教显贵，你肯定不想实际上成为阿拉伯人的仆人或附庸。汤姆，我们今天是在我们的公立学校系列节目播出后录制的。你已经从级长变成了低年级杂役，对吧？没错。所以，对于那些相对富有的人来说，这尤其是一种屈辱。
off among the ranks of non-Muslims, but even peasants. So there's an incident in the reign of Abdul Malik, the great Maid Caliph who builds the Dome of the Rock. A whole band of Iraqi peasants convert en masse to Islam and say, well, you know, we no longer need to work the fields because we are now Muslims. We are equal with all the Arabs. And they go off to Basra, which is the great port on the Persian Gulf. And Abdul Malik sends his best general after them. He rounds them up and he returns them to the estate of their masters. So there is no sense there in that kind of behavior that the egalitarianism that is so much a feature of the Quran's doctrines is being practiced by the Umayyads at all.
不仅在非穆斯林中，甚至在农民中也是如此。阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）统治时期发生过一件事，这位伟大的倭马亚哈里发建造了圆顶清真寺。一群伊拉克农民集体皈依伊斯兰教，并说，你知道，我们不再需要耕种土地了，因为我们现在是穆斯林。我们与所有阿拉伯人平等。于是他们前往波斯湾的大港口巴士拉。阿卜杜勒·马利克派他最优秀的将军去追捕他们。他把他们抓起来，送回了他们主人的庄园。因此，在这种行为中，根本看不出倭马亚王朝在实践《古兰经》教义中那种非常显著的平等主义。
But all that said, Tom, you look at the demography of the Middle East right now, or indeed a few centuries after the point about which we're talking, obviously people do convert, don't they, in massive numbers. So how does that happen? I think in two ways. So the first is that the Arab Empire, like the Roman Empire before it, reaps a vast number of slaves. I mean, a huge number of slaves. So there's a monk who describes the process of Arab slave raiding. And he writes, annually, their robber bands went to distant parts
但话虽如此，汤姆，看看现在中东的人口结构，或者确实在我们谈论的那个时间点之后的几个世纪，显然人们确实在大规模地皈依，不是吗？那么这是怎么发生的呢？我认为有两种方式。第一种是阿拉伯帝国像之前的罗马帝国一样，掠夺了大量的奴隶。我是说，数量巨大的奴隶。有一位僧侣描述了阿拉伯人劫掠奴隶的过程。他写道，每年，他们的强盗团伙都会前往遥远的地方
and to the islands. So that's the islands in the Mediterranean, bringing back captives from all the peoples under the heavens. This is not an exaggeration. So huge numbers of Persians are brought to the slave markets of Kufa and Basra. From the furthest most west, Visigoths from Spain, 8,000 are led in chains from Spain all the way to the slave market in Damascus. When the Arabs cross the Pyrenees, they're rounding people up there and sending them off to the slave markets as well. And often when cities surrender to the Arabs, a kind of tithe of slaves is part of the deal. So there's a fortress called Zaranj, which again, brilliant name, that commands the approaches to the Hindu Kush. And it's agreed as part of the terms of the surrender of the people of Zaranj, that every year
以及各个岛屿。也就是地中海的岛屿，从天下万民中带回俘虏。这并非夸大其词。大量的波斯人被带到库法和巴士拉的奴隶市场。从最遥远的西方，来自西班牙的西哥特人，8000人被戴上锁链，一路从西班牙押送到大马士革的奴隶市场。当阿拉伯人越过比利牛斯山脉时，他们也在那里搜捕人们，并将他们送往奴隶市场。通常当城市向阿拉伯人投降时，某种形式的奴隶什一税是交易的一部分。有一个叫扎兰季（Zaranj）的堡垒，名字很棒，它控制着通往兴都库什山的通道。作为扎兰季人民投降条款的一部分，双方商定每年
they will deliver up to the Umayyad court, a thousand of their most beautiful boys, and each one will hold in his hands a golden cup. And this for the Muslims is a kind of foretaste of the joys of paradise. And these are sex slaves, Tom? Absolutely. Yes. I mean, again, very like the Romans, but also there are a lot of girls being enslaved as well. And so Abdul Malik, builder of the Dome of the Rock, terrible halitosis was said to be able to kill a fly with a single blast of his breath. He said of the sheer range of different kinds of girl that you could have. He defines them culturally. He says that if you wish to take a slave girl for pleasure,
他们将向倭马亚宫廷进贡一千名他们最漂亮的男孩，每个人手里都要拿着一个金杯。对于穆斯林来说，这是一种天堂之乐的预尝。这些是性奴隶吗，汤姆？绝对是。是的。我的意思是，这和罗马人非常像，但也有很多女孩被奴役。所以阿卜杜勒·马利克，圆顶清真寺的建造者，据说有严重的口臭，一口气就能吹死一只苍蝇。他谈到了你可以拥有的各种女孩的范围。他从文化上定义了她们。他说，如果你想找一个奴隶女孩来取乐，
then take a Berber slave girl. If you wish to take one as a domestic servant, someone who'll do your housework, take a Roman. And if you wish to have one that will give you a child, then take a Persian. So again, this idea that the Persians are particularly good at breeding continuous bloodlines. Is that because the Persians are the most prestigious in the Arab sense? There's the most high status empire, would you say? Well, because they've conquered it completely. It means that the Persian aristocracy are there waiting to be enslaved. And even Sasanian princesses are enslaved. So they're kind of
那就找一个柏柏尔奴隶女孩。如果你想找一个做家务的仆人，找一个罗马人。如果你想找一个能为你生孩子的，那就找一个波斯人。所以，这种认为波斯人特别擅长繁衍连续血统的观念再次出现。这是因为波斯人在阿拉伯人眼中地位最高吗？你会说这是地位最高的帝国吗？嗯，因为他们已经完全征服了它。这意味着波斯贵族在那里等着被奴役。甚至萨珊王朝的公主也被奴役了。所以她们被安置在
set up in beautiful palaces, but they're still slaves. This is basically what's going on. And obviously the effect of the transplantation and intermingling of all these different peoples coming from all the various corners of the world is very profound because they're bringing with them their different customs, their different understanding of the gods, and they're serving out their term of slavery. Again, as in the Roman world, I think we talked about this before. As a slave in the Roman world, if you're a domestic slave, the likelihood is at some point you will be freed. And so there's a sense in which being a slave is like earning your green card.
漂亮的宫殿里，但她们仍然是奴隶。这基本上就是正在发生的事情。显然，来自世界各个角落的所有这些不同民族的迁移和融合，其影响是非常深远的，因为他们带来了不同的习俗、对神的不同理解，并且正在服完他们的奴役期。同样，正如在罗马世界一样，我想我们之前讨论过这个问题。作为罗马世界的奴隶，如果你是家奴，很有可能在某个时候你会获得自由。所以某种意义上，成为奴隶就像获得了绿卡。
You will become a part of the Roman order once your master frees you. The same is true in the Islamic world, because again, Muhammad himself had been a slave owner. It's absolutely licit for Muslims to own slaves, but at the same time, it is seen as a pious thing to do to free slaves. And so lots of these people, women, men, being brought to Kufa or to Damascus or whatever, they're serving their term of servitude, and then they're being released released and they are joining the kind of the mix. And over the course of their servitude, they will have become Muslim almost certainly because it will make their life easier. So this is a kind of supply of Muslims that is feeding into these great cosmopolitan cities. And what if you're not allowed to sit in the presence of an Arab. You're not allowed to wear a sword. You're not allowed to ride in a saddle. If you do ride, you have to ride a mule and you have to do
一旦你的主人释放你，你就会成为罗马秩序的一部分。在伊斯兰世界也是如此，因为穆罕默德本人也曾是奴隶主。穆斯林拥有奴隶是完全合法的，但同时，释放奴隶也被视为一种虔诚的行为。所以这些人，无论男女，被带到库法或大马士革等地，他们服完奴役期，然后被释放，并加入到这种混合体中。在他们服役期间，他们几乎肯定会成为穆斯林，因为这会让他们的生活更容易。所以这是一种正在向这些伟大的国际化城市输送穆斯林的供应。如果你不被允许坐在阿拉伯人面前怎么办？你不被允许佩剑。你不被允许骑马。如果你骑马，你必须骑骡子，而且你必须像女人一样
it side saddle like a woman. And all of this is, you know, I mean, it's not terminal. You can live with these kinds of indignities, but they are indignities. And so you probably do want to get out of them. And there are increasing numbers of people who are prepared to kind of accept that they get a Muslim patron and become Muslim. So gradually, over the course of the century or so that follows the Arab conquests, you do see more and more people starting to become Muslim. And particularly, you start to see Zoroastrians for the reasons that we talked about. But in a sense, for the Zoroastrians, the experience of conquest by the Arabs has been worse than for Jews and Christians. And I think that for Zoroastrians in particular, it's not just
侧着骑。所有这些，你知道，我的意思是，这并不是致命的。你可以忍受这些屈辱，但它们确实是屈辱。所以你可能确实想摆脱它们。越来越多的人准备接受这一点，他们找一个穆斯林赞助人并成为穆斯林。因此，在阿拉伯征服后的一个世纪左右的时间里，你确实看到越来越多的人开始成为穆斯林。特别是，你开始看到琐罗亚斯德教徒，原因我们已经讨论过了。但在某种意义上，对于琐罗亚斯德教徒来说，被阿拉伯人征服的经历比犹太人和基督徒更糟糕。我认为对于琐罗亚斯德教徒来说，这不仅仅
about trying to escape the taxes and the indignities. It is also about wanting to find meaning in a world where everything that you've been familiar with has been destroyed. And so practices that are Zoroastrian over the course of the century or so, the following the Arab conquest, start to appear in Islamic practice. So for instance, the five daily prayers that Muslims have, this is not prescribed in the Quran, but it comes to be seen as a kind of statutory requirement for Muslims as it had been for Zoroastrians. The notion that if you become an apostate, if you abandon your faith, you should be put to death. Again, this is not in the Quran,
是为了试图逃避税收和屈辱。这也是为了在一切你所熟悉的事物都被摧毁的世界中寻找意义。因此，在阿拉伯征服后的一个世纪左右的时间里，琐罗亚斯德教的习俗开始出现在伊斯兰教的实践中。例如，穆斯林的每日五次礼拜，这在《古兰经》中没有规定，但它逐渐被视为穆斯林的一种法定要求，就像它对琐罗亚斯德教徒一样。如果你成为叛教者，如果你放弃你的信仰，你就应该被处死。同样，这不在《古兰经》中，
but it is a Zoroastrian tradition. Most intriguing of all, perhaps, the idea that it's a mark of piety to use a toothbrush. So you start to get all kinds of Arab stories that the Muhammad was obsessed with cleaning his teeth. And again, this seems to come from Zoroastrian practice. They were very, very keen on dental hygiene. That is a stunning revelation to me. The only person I can think of like that in the modern world is Martin Amis, Tom. Well, there's a comparison that's never been made before. He was very interested in teeth.
但这是琐罗亚斯德教的传统。也许最引人注目的是，使用牙刷被视为虔诚的标志。所以你开始听到各种各样的阿拉伯故事，说穆罕默德痴迷于清洁牙齿。同样，这似乎来自琐罗亚斯德教的习俗。他们非常非常热衷于牙齿卫生。这对我来说是一个惊人的启示。在现代世界，我能想到的唯一像那样的人是马丁·艾米斯（Martin Amis），汤姆。嗯，这是一个以前从未做过的比较。他对牙齿非常感兴趣。
Is this really, what, using a toothbrush is seen as the mark of a pious Muslim? Yes, because Muhammad did it. Surely Muhammad must have done it. He wasn't the first person in human history to use a toothbrush is seen as the mark of a pious Muslim. Yes, because Muhammad did it. Surely Muhammad must have done it. He wasn't the first person in human history to use a toothbrush, John. No, because probably the historical Muhammad didn't do it. This is coming from Zoroastrianism. So that's the question. How did these traditions that seem to be Zoroastrian end up becoming part of Muslim practice when
这真的是，什么，使用牙刷被视为虔诚穆斯林的标志吗？是的，因为穆罕默德做了。穆罕默德肯定做过。他不是人类历史上第一个使用牙刷的人。是的，因为穆罕默德做了。穆罕默德肯定做过。他不是人类历史上第一个使用牙刷的人，约翰。不，因为历史上的穆罕默德可能并没有这样做。这是来自琐罗亚斯德教。所以问题就在这里。这些看起来像是琐罗亚斯德教的传统，是如何在
they weren't initially, often even overriding the dictates of the Quran? I mean, how is this process happening? And I think the answer is coming not so much from Zoroastrian conversion, but from Jewish conversion. Because Dominic, you will remember, I talked about the very, very distinctive understanding of law that the rabbis in- You did. That was thrilling. In Iraq- Yeah. I wondered where it was going. I thought it was a bit tangential. Okay. So in Jewish practice, in the great cities of Mesopotamia, these rabbinical schools, these yeshivas, you have this idea of a written law, Torah, and a spoken law, which is the Talmud.
它们最初并不存在的情况下，最终成为穆斯林实践的一部分的，甚至往往凌驾于《古兰经》的指令之上？我的意思是，这个过程是如何发生的？我认为答案不是来自琐罗亚斯德教的皈依，而是来自犹太教的皈依。因为多米尼克，你会记得，我谈到了拉比们对法律非常、非常独特的理解——你谈到了。那太令人兴奋了。在伊拉克——是的。我想知道它会走向何方。我觉得它有点离题。好吧。所以在犹太教的实践中，在美索不达米亚的伟大城市里，这些拉比学校，这些经学院，你有这种成文法（托拉）和口传法（塔木德）的概念。
And over the course of the century or so, following the Arab conquest, you start to see the same in Islam. So you have the Quran, which is the equivalent of Torah, and you start to get vast body of sayings that are attributed first to the companions of the Prophet and then increasingly to the Prophet himself. These are called hadiths. Yeah. If you're a very strict, observant Muslim, you would undoubtedly say, listen, these are absolutely bona fide, 24 karats. This is absolutely what the prophet said. If you're a sceptical non-Muslim historian, you might say these are cobbled together from other traditions, decades or indeed centuries after the event. I think cobbling together is perhaps an overly negative way of
在阿拉伯征服后的一个世纪左右的时间里，你开始在伊斯兰教中看到同样的情况。所以你有《古兰经》，它相当于托拉，你开始得到大量的言论，这些言论首先归功于先知的同伴，然后越来越多地归功于先知本人。这些被称为圣训（Hadiths）。是的。如果你是一个非常严格、虔诚的穆斯林，你无疑会说，听着，这些绝对是货真价实的，24K纯金。这绝对是先知所说的。如果你是一个持怀疑态度的非穆斯林历史学家，你可能会说这些是在事件发生几十年甚至几个世纪后从其他传统中拼凑出来的。我认为“拼凑”可能是一个过于负面的
framing it. So great efforts are made by Muslim scholars, exactly as they had been made by Jewish scholars, to show that these sayings, if they're attributed to the prophet or to the companions of the prophet, did authentically come from them. So they're called isnad, they are so-and-so told so-and-so who told so-and-so who told so-and-so who'd heard it from the prophet. So these chains. But I think it's very difficult to place much confidence in them as authentically historical. And I think it's pretty clear that what is happening is that the influence of the Talmud on what will come to be called the Sunnah. So the sunnah is the great body of spoken law, the laws that derive from the sayings of the prophet. The idea for this, I mean,
框架。所以穆斯林学者做出了巨大的努力，正如犹太学者所做的那样，来证明这些言论，如果它们归功于先知或先知的同伴，确实是真实地来自他们。所以它们被称为“传述链”（isnad），即某某人告诉某某人，某某人告诉某某人，某某人听先知说的。所以这些链条。但我认为很难对它们作为真实的历史记录抱有太大的信心。我认为很明显正在发生的事情是塔木德对后来被称为“圣行”（Sunnah）的影响。所以圣行是伟大的口传法体系，即源于先知言论的法律。这个想法，我的意思是，
it would be a massive coincidence if these two very distinctive ways of understanding divine law, that you have a written law and a spoken law, should magically appear in the same region of the world at the same time. I mean, it seems to me impossible that the one is not influencing the other. And it's kind of brilliant if you want to import the things that you believe as a Jew or a Christian or a Zoroastrian into the growing emergent fabric of Islam, then this offers you the way to do it. Because you can say, oh, the companion of the Prophet said X, and it just happens to match our use of toothbrushes or whatever. Absolutely. Yes. So you're a Zoroastrian, you know that dental hygiene is very important. There's nothing in the Quran about dental hygiene.
如果这两种对神圣法律的非常独特的理解方式——即你有成文法和口传法——神奇地同时出现在世界的同一个地区，那将是一个巨大的巧合。我的意思是，在我看来，一个不影响另一个是不可能的。如果你想把你作为犹太人、基督徒或琐罗亚斯德教徒所相信的东西引入到伊斯兰教正在形成的结构中，这提供了一种方式，这真是太棒了。因为你可以说，哦，先知的同伴说了X，而它恰好符合我们使用牙刷的习惯等等。绝对是。是的。所以你是一个琐罗亚斯德教徒，你知道牙齿卫生非常重要。《古兰经》里没有关于牙齿卫生的内容。
So you say, well, I know that the Prophet did it, and here's the proof, here's the great chain of Isnad, here's the Hadith, and it gets incorporated into the fabric of Islamic law, which lawyers and scholars are starting to compile over the decades. And there you go. And it's absolutely brilliant. Tom, I don't want to send this totally off-piste. Just to be absolutely clear, the Romans brushed their teeth, didn't they? I'm really, I don i'm really i don't know you don't know i mean yes they did they did but i think they had it's a particular kind of twig right but the toothbrush specifically is persian that's what you're claiming i believe so it's
所以你说，嗯，我知道先知做了，这是证据，这是伟大的传述链，这是圣训，它被纳入了伊斯兰法律的结构中，律师和学者们几十年来一直在汇编这些法律。就是这样。这绝对是天才。汤姆，我不想让话题完全偏离。为了绝对清楚，罗马人刷牙，对吧？我真的，我不知道，你不知道，我的意思是，是的，他们刷了，他们刷了，但我认为他们有一种特定的树枝，对吧？但牙刷具体是波斯的，这就是你所声称的，我相信是这样，所以它
actually quite a long time since i did my research into personal dental hygiene but i believe so okay so we could we could perhaps pay a visit to the bodleian and do an episode no i think we should absolutely return to this topic in greater depth at a future date but in the meantime press on with towards baghdad well the implication of this is astounding because basically it means that the conquered people the jews the christ, the Zoroastrians, when they become Muslim, they're not simply kind of passively absorbing the teachings of Islam. They are contributing to it. They're shaping it, right? They're shaping it. Exactly. And they're able to read the Quran as well as anyone. And in the
实际上距离我研究个人牙齿卫生已经过去很长时间了，但我相信是这样。好吧，所以我们也许可以去博德利图书馆（Bodleian）做一期节目。不，我认为我们绝对应该在未来的某个日期更深入地回到这个话题，但与此同时，继续向巴格达进发。嗯，这意味着什么，这太令人震惊了，因为这基本上意味着被征服的人民，犹太人、基督徒、琐罗亚斯德教徒，当他们成为穆斯林时，他们不仅仅是被动地吸收伊斯兰教的教义。他们正在为之做出贡献。他们在塑造它，对吧？他们在塑造它。完全正确。而且他们也能像任何人一样阅读《古兰经》。在
Quran, they can see that it's forbidden for the powerful and the rich to grind the poor into the dust or their inferiors into the dust. And so they can turn the teachings of the Quran against their masters. So it's rather like Fanon or someone like that turning Western ideas against Western imperialism. It's the same kind of idea. Or African-American slaves who have conversed to Christianity saying, whoa, whoa, whoa, you preach about the Bible, but the Bible explicitly says, be kind, don't torture and repress people. Yes. Except that in Christianity, unlike in Judaism and Islam, you don't have a written
《古兰经》中，他们可以看到，权贵和富人禁止将穷人或下属踩在脚下。所以他们可以利用《古兰经》的教义来反对他们的主人。这有点像法农（Fanon）或类似的人利用西方思想来反对西方帝国主义。这是同样的想法。或者皈依基督教的非裔美国奴隶说，嘿，嘿，嘿，你们宣扬圣经，但圣经明确说，要仁慈，不要折磨和压迫人民。是的。只不过在基督教中，不像在犹太教和伊斯兰教中，你没有成文的
body of law. That's the way in which Islam is most like Judaism, that it does have this body of law. And so what is happening over the century or so that follows the emergence of Islam, originally, is that what initially had been a kind of inchoate swirl of beliefs and doctrines and teachings starts to be transformed into basically a religion of lawyers. These lawyers overwhelmingly seem to be coming from the body of the conquered people. So it's kind of as a check upon the arrogance, the sense of superiority of an imperial elite, it's a completely remarkable counterblast from a defeated people. I mean, nothing like it had been seen before, really. So this is what's going on. And you can see how and why this would be dangerous for the
法律体系。这就是伊斯兰教最像犹太教的地方，它确实有这套法律体系。所以，在伊斯兰教出现后的一个世纪左右的时间里，最初那种模糊的信仰、教义和教导的漩涡开始被转化为基本上是一种律师的宗教。这些律师绝大多数似乎来自被征服的人民。所以，作为对帝国精英傲慢和优越感的一种制衡，这是来自被征服人民的完全非凡的反击。我的意思是，真的，以前从未见过类似的事情。所以这就是正在发生的事情。你可以看出为什么这对
Umayyads, because the Umayyads are kind of old school autocrats. These are people with enormous palaces, with soldiers, people who are taking lots of slaves. And they have all these kind of lawyers who are starting to emerge in cities across Mesopotamia saying, well, actually, you can't behave like this. This is very bad. And the other thing, of course, is that looking back to the time before the Umayyads, so back to the time of the Rashidun, the rightly guided caliphs, and Muhammad himself, it puts the Umayyads in a very bad light. Because if these teachings of Muhammad have been forgotten, as the emergence of the sunnah implies, that's the foundation for it,
倭马亚王朝来说是危险的，因为倭马亚人是老派的独裁者。这些人拥有巨大的宫殿，拥有士兵，拥有大量奴隶。他们有所有这些开始在美索不达米亚各城市出现的律师，他们说，嗯，实际上，你不能这样行事。这非常糟糕。当然，另一件事是，回顾倭马亚王朝之前的时间，即正统哈里发时期和穆罕默德本人时期，这让倭马亚人显得非常糟糕。因为如果穆罕默德的这些教导已经被遗忘，正如圣行的出现所暗示的那样，那是它的基础，
then whose fault is it that they were forgotten? It's obviously the Umayyads. The Umayyads are presiding over a sinister, apostate regime. And so increasingly, the Umayyad caliphs come to be cast not as defenders of the faithful, but as the enemies of the faithful. So they're pampered, gilded autocrats being challenged by a puritanical new, and elite's the wrong word, new class. Is that the right way of putting it? Yeah, a new class. I mean, to the Umayyads, the fact that all these, they're Persians and Jews and Turks and people, they're kind of pen pushers. They're kind of blotter daughters. I mean, who are these foreigners, these pen pushers to tell the
那么忘记它们是谁的错呢？显然是倭马亚人的错。倭马亚人正在主持一个邪恶的、叛教的政权。因此，倭马亚哈里发越来越多地被视为不是信徒的捍卫者，而是信徒的敌人。所以他们是被宠坏的、镀金的独裁者，受到清教徒式的新——“精英”这个词用错了——新阶级的挑战。这是正确的说法吗？是的，一个新阶级。我的意思是，对倭马亚人来说，所有这些波斯人、犹太人、土耳其人等等，他们只是某种文书。他们是某种……我的意思是，这些外国人、这些文书是谁，竟敢告诉
deputy of God what he should be doing? But this is the process that's happening. And so this is why in the 740s, when you've got military reverses on the frontiers, you've got sectarianism within Islam breaking out with the Karajites and with the Shiites. You also have this vast kind of emergence of lawyers equipped with a way of undermining the entire moral basis of Umayyad rule. And increasingly, they are targeting everything that had enabled the Umayyads to seem dazzling rulers. The wealth of the Umayyads and their fellow Arab warlords, the wealth that they've garnered from across the world, the spices, the peacock silks, the beard dye. So great fashion for of dying their beards yellow and red cranky so lo and
上帝的代理人他应该做什么？但这就是正在发生的过程。这就是为什么在740年代，当你在边境遭遇军事挫折时，伊斯兰教内部出现了哈瓦利吉派（Karajites）和什叶派（Shiites）的宗派主义。你还有这种庞大的律师群体，他们装备了一种破坏倭马亚统治整个道德基础的方法。他们越来越多地针对所有使倭马亚人显得耀眼的统治者的东西。倭马亚人和他们的阿拉伯军阀同僚的财富，他们从世界各地搜刮来的财富，香料，孔雀丝，胡须染料。所以非常流行把胡须染成黄色和红色，古怪的，所以瞧，
behold this is this is condemned as as being very sinister probably doesn't fit well with the dental hygiene i wouldn't have thought anyway that's by the by obsessed with the dental hygiene yeah and so you get you know there's people in the slums of kufa or of basra are looking at all this and saying this is not what the prophet said. They'll quote the Quran. You do not honor the orphan, nor urge one another to feed the poor. You consume an inheritance to the last mouthful and you love wealth with a love inordinate. These are the words of God as mediated through the prophet that the conquered peoples can now turn back against the Umayyads. So in other words,
瞧，这被谴责为非常邪恶，可能与牙齿卫生不太相符，我本来没这么想。无论如何，那是题外话。痴迷于牙齿卫生，是的。所以你看到，库法或巴士拉贫民窟的人们看着这一切说，这不是先知所说的。他们会引用《古兰经》。你们不尊重孤儿，也不互相劝勉喂养穷人。你们贪婪地吞食遗产，你们极其热爱财富。这些是上帝通过先知传达的话语，被征服的人民现在可以转而反对倭马亚人。换句话说，
it's not just the sectarians, the Shia, the Karajites who have incentive and means to oppose the Umayyads, but actually the vast mass of the people who are becoming Muslim in Iraq. And so, you know, this is very, very bad for the Umayyads who in any way are based in Syria. Iraq is increasingly becoming ungovernable. And on top of that, there are then two further disastrous developments. And the first is that the Umayyads start fighting one another. So there's a tremendous caliph, who's the grandson of Abdul Malik, called Al-Walid, who is an alcoholic, and he's absolutely obsessed with sex. He's kind of nymphomaniac.
不仅仅是宗派主义者，什叶派、哈瓦利吉派有动机和手段反对倭马亚人，而且实际上是伊拉克正在成为穆斯林的广大民众。所以，你知道，这对倭马亚人来说非常非常糟糕，他们无论如何都以叙利亚为基地。伊拉克正变得越来越难以治理。最重要的是，随后又发生了两起灾难性的事态发展。第一是倭马亚人开始互相残杀。有一位伟大的哈里发，是阿卜杜勒·马利克的孙子，名叫瓦利德（Al-Walid），他是个酒鬼，而且绝对痴迷于性。他有点性欲亢进。
And he is assassinated in one of his desert pleasure palaces in 744. And this precipitates a kind of mass bloodletting among his relatives. And the man who emerges victorious from this, this kind of the great war of the Umayyad cousins is a guy called Marwan, who's very grizzled, has curly hair, a veteran of many battles, and a pretty proficient military leader. And by 747, he is undisputed as caliph, but it's come at terrible cost because he's lost the support of many Omeyad loyalists. Civil war has brought ruin to many of the cities in Syria as well as in Iraq. And in fact, he is so hated in Syria that he abandons it completely, goes to live in a town called Haran. So that's bad.
他在744年被暗杀在他的一座沙漠享乐宫殿中。这引发了他的亲属之间的大规模流血事件。从这场倭马亚表亲的大战中脱颖而出的胜利者是一个叫马尔万（Marwan）的人，他非常灰白，留着卷发，是许多战斗的老兵，也是一位相当精通军事的领导人。到747年，他作为哈里发无可争议，但这付出了惨重的代价，因为他失去了许多倭马亚忠诚者的支持。内战给叙利亚和伊拉克的许多城市带来了毁灭。事实上，他在叙利亚非常不受欢迎，以至于他完全放弃了那里，去了一个叫哈兰（Haran）的城镇居住。所以这很糟糕。
But what's even worse is that a rival dynasty has appeared. And this is a dynasty that is capable of appealing to Sunnis. So these people in Iraq who are saying that the Umayyads are autocrats, that they're like Caesars, that they're like pharaohs, that there should be a new regime, there should be a revolution that overthrows them and enshrines a rule of equality and justice and charity. So they're able to appeal to them, but they're also able to appeal to the Shia, this idea that there is a holy bloodline. Because this dynasty, the Abbasids claim descent from Abbas, who is the uncle of Muhammad. So there you have a kind of sense that both the Shia and
但更糟糕的是，一个敌对的王朝出现了。这是一个能够吸引逊尼派的王朝。所以伊拉克的这些人说倭马亚人是独裁者，他们像凯撒，像法老，应该有一个新的政权，应该有一场推翻他们并确立平等、正义和慈善统治的革命。所以他们能够吸引他们，但他们也能够吸引什叶派，即存在神圣血统的观念。因为这个王朝，阿拔斯王朝（Abbasids），声称是穆罕默德的叔叔阿拔斯（Abbas）的后裔。所以你有一种感觉，什叶派和
the Sunni can kind of meet in loyalty to the Abbasids, the descendants of Abbas, the uncle of Muhammad. And agents of the Abbasids start to fan out. They start to suborn people in Iraq. They particularly start to suborn people in Khorasan, that vast stretch of lands heading eastwards from Iran. And the whole Umayyad world, Dominic, it's a tinderbox. It's a tinderbox just waiting for the spark, Tom. Waiting for the spark. Is that the image you were looking for? That's the image. I don't think anyone's ever used that before.
逊尼派都可以在对阿拔斯王朝的忠诚中相遇，即穆罕默德叔叔阿拔斯的后裔。阿拔斯王朝的代理人开始散布。他们开始在伊拉克收买人心。他们特别开始在呼罗珊（Khorasan）收买人心，那是从伊朗向东延伸的广阔土地。整个倭马亚世界，多米尼克，就是一个火药桶。就是一个等待火花的火药桶，汤姆。等待火花。那是你在寻找的意象吗？那就是意象。我想以前没人用过这个。
People are dancing on the edge of an abyss, aren't they? They are on the edge of a volcano, Dominic. Fantastic. So, Tom, what a cliffhanger. And the good news is, if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, so in other words, if you're paying tribute to us, then you can listen to that episode where Tom describes the war between the Umayyads and the Abbasids, the great Abbasid revolution. And then at last, we'll get back to where we started with the foundation of the great city of peace, the round city of Baghdad,
人们在深渊边缘跳舞，不是吗？他们在火山边缘，多米尼克。太棒了。所以，汤姆，真是个悬念。好消息是，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”（Rest Is History Club）的成员，换句话说，如果你在向我们致敬，那么你可以收听那一集，汤姆描述了倭马亚王朝和阿拔斯王朝之间的战争，伟大的阿拔斯革命。然后最后，我们将回到我们开始的地方，即伟大和平之城、圆形城市巴格达的建立，
the greatest city at that point in human history. So we'll get back to that next time. You can listen to that now if you're a member of the Rest is History Club. If you're not, if you're a person of the book, so in other words, that means you just listen to the Rest is History, but you're not really part of the elite, then you'll just have to wait until Thursday. But I hope it'll be worth waiting for because the story of the Abbasid Revolution is a brilliant, brilliant narrative. And then the founding of Baghdad, very, very romantic, epical moment in world history. So very, very thrilling. It could not be a more exciting story.
那是当时人类历史上最伟大的城市。所以我们下次会回到那个话题。如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，你现在就可以收听。如果你不是，如果你是“书本之人”，换句话说，这意味着你只是听“历史其余部分”，但你并不是真正的精英阶层，那么你将不得不等到周四。但我希望等待是值得的，因为阿拔斯革命的故事是一个辉煌、辉煌的叙事。然后是巴格达的建立，世界历史上非常、非常浪漫、史诗般的时刻。所以非常、非常令人兴奋。这不可能是一个更令人兴奋的故事了。
And if we're really lucky, Tom will talk to us a little bit more about toothbrushes. No more toothbrushes. And on that note, goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
如果我们真的很幸运，汤姆会再多跟我们谈谈牙刷。没有牙刷了。说到这里，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持“娱乐其余部分”（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。